Now, this very strange structure here
is called a domatium.
And what it is, is a house for ants.
And this plant has built this little structure.
It's sort of like a barracks for the ant army.
They live inside.
And when herbivores arrive, the ant army
comes out of the domatium
and attacks the herbivores.
And we can see, I think, if I get this,
put this in the light, you can see
these little holes and that's where the ants
live.
And the plant can spend up to 20% of all it's
resources housing and feeding its army.
And each plant has a relationship
with a particular kind of ant species.
And each kind of ant signals
to its plant and vice versa.
So this is a system where
the ants and the plants talk to each other.
Now, this system of defence
takes a lot of resources.
Ants are quite fussy, they like
nice big houses, thank you very much.
And they like lots of food.
You've got to keep your army loyal
by feeding it well.
So, this is an expensive kind
of defence so it's got to work.
And now we're going to see
this defence in action.
We're going to see what happens
when caterpillars and ants meet each other.
Now, in here, we've got our resident ant army.
Now hopefully you can see these
guys running about. They're on patrol.
They're waiting for something to attack.
And we've got some caterpillars.
So I'm now going to see
what happens when I put a caterpillar
into the middle of this ant army.
Now what are the ants going to make of that?
Ooh.
They're not very happy at this intruder.
So they're going to come and bite our caterpillar.
Ooh yes.
They're on the attack.
You can see that, oh dear,
yes this Colin the caterpillar
and I don't think
he's enjoying that very much.
Yes, the ants are busy
trying to kill poor old Colin.
And they're very, very aggressive as you can
see.
Lots of them are surrounding
the caterpillar and poor old...
Should we rescue Colin?
- Yes!
It's a bit hard actually,
the ants don't want to let go.
Now ants are very, very fierce.
Don't worry, I think Colin will recover in
the end.
I'll go and rescue him properly in a moment.
But ants are some of the fiercest predators
and they are very aggressive.
About a third of the trees in
tropical countries are protected by ants,
as I discovered when I took a party of students
into the forest in Uganda a couple of summers
ago,
and we accidentally walked into trees protected
by ants.
They poured out of the tree and attacked us.
And the only thing we could do,
because it was so painful and horrible,
was run away as fast as we could and
then we discovered the ants were in our clothes.
So we had to take all our clothes off.
Which wasn't a pretty sight on lots of levels,
and we had to take all the ants off.
And they were so aggressive they wouldn't
let go.
So is this a very, very good defence.
And the ants are an incredibly loyal army.
They don't just kill herbivores like Colin
and attack people like me,
what they do is they kill other plants.
So they make sure that their own plant
has all the best resources
and they kill all the plants surrounding their
home.